you are watching cold fusion tv
[Music]
hi welcome to another cold fusion video
volkswagen pretty much everyone on the
planet knows that name
but the thing is this company is a bit
of a dark horse they actually own a lot
of car brands which you've heard of
in fact every fourth car sold in europe
is from the volkswagen group
volkswagen has been a popular suggestion
for a video so let's do it
in this video we'll talk about the
intriguing origins size
and some interesting facts about vw
volkswagen translated from german to
english means
the people's car and that's exactly what
the company was created for back in 1937
to make a car for the people of germany
in order to understand and really
appreciate the history of vw
we must look at where it all started
with a man named ferdinand and a car
called the beatle
the beatle was the brainchild of
ferdinand porsche who was the son of a
master panel beater
porsche was born in 1875 in northern
bohemia
all modern day czech republic from a
young age he was a non-conformist and a
free thinker but possessed a brilliant
mind for design
in 1900 as a teenager he designed the
world's first front-wheel drive car
the loner electric chavez his unorthodox
front wheel drive concept won him many
design awards
and even got accepted into the higher
echelons of society
austrian archduke franz ferdinand owned
one of porsche's early cars
over the next decade the acclaimed
designer would leave his mark in
automotive racing
civilian cars and even aircraft engines
which he designed for austria during
world war one
it doesn't stop there though during this
time he even created the first gasoline
electric hybrid car
while this would be a lifetime's work
for most his real passion lay in the
vehicle for the common man
you see at the time in the early 1900s
cars in europe were seen as a toy for
the very rich
but ferdinand had seen what henry ford
had done in america with the ford model
t and he thought he could do the same
for europe with this idea
he tried to convince a number of
european companies to take on his idea
of a small
rear-engined affordable car but he was
let down each and every time
from this he decided to just start his
own company now
he was free to do as he pleased
ferdinand noted that the cars of the day
were too tall and not aerodynamic enough
he wanted to build a car that was slick
yet affordable
while trying to get financial backing
for this new project porsche was once
again
let down numerous times this was until
1933.
it was in this year that a friend in the
industry brought him into contact with a
man named
adolf hitler he was the freshly elected
chancellor of germany and the leader of
the national socialist german workers
party
otherwise known as the nazi party
for some context in the early 1930s
hitler was seen as a man who could lift
germany out of a terrible economic
situation
and restore strength to a demoralized
population
of course as history tells us he turned
out to be something quite different in
the end
at this time hitler was looking to show
how advanced nazism was to the world
one way of showing this superiority was
through engineering
hitler proposed that any german company
that could build a race car for the
upcoming grand prix
season would win 250 000 rush marks
ferdinand porsche's engineering designs
dominated the 1934 racing season
and because of this he was contracted to
make three prototype cars by the german
government
in part these new cars were to be
designed for sustained high speeds on
the newly revived autobahn project
the outcome of this contract would be
the volkswagen beetle
[Music]
strangely the beetle was originally
going to be called the strength
through joy car strength through joy
that's a bit of a strange name you might
be thinking
well strength through joy was the title
of the leisure branch within the nazi
party
this branch was in charge of making the
middle class leisure activities
affordable and available to the masses
after the brutal economic slump of the
1920s
these state-sponsored activities
included concerts
plays libraries day trips and holidays
they also built large cruise ships and
wanted to encourage tourism to germany
the people's car was just a small part
of this vision
the beetle wasn't to be built for speed
or beauty with a top speed not far above
100 kilometers an hour and a market
price of 390 us dollars
it was built to do just one thing move
people reliably and economically
the car was to be built by a new firm
created by the german labour front in
volkswagen if you want to see something
interesting
take a look at this photo from 1938 this
is adolf hitler laying the cornerstone
for the original vw factory
the unassuming sullen character to the
far right is ferdinand porsche
it's moments like this in history that
could be called simultaneously
fascinating
and frightening
[Music]
the strength through droid prototype car
was on track for 300 000 orders
but at that moment the world was about
to be shocked by the biggest conflict in
world history up to that day
in 1939 hitler invaded poland and world
war ii broke out
at this stage only a handful of cars
were complete and none were delivered to
customers
germany went into full crisis mode and
diverted all attention towards the war
effort
the volkswagen factory began
manufacturing military vehicles
including an amphibious version of the
beetle prototype
and the infamous v1 flying bomb this
manufacturing of military equipment made
the factory a major bombing target
in 1945 when the war ended and peace
enveloped the world
like most of europe the vw factory lay
in ruined
in an extremely strange twist of fate an
undetonated bomb was found lodged
between the factory's main power
generators
if it had exploded that would have
marked the end of volkswagen
meanwhile ferdinand porsche was
imprisoned in france for working for
hitler
at 72 years old it was looking like
porsche's dream of the small car for the
masses
may not come to reality but he didn't
give up
upon his release from prison he spent
countless hours on the manufacturing
floor
listening to what workers had to say and
absorbing their ideas
at this time the situation in germany
was dire and some citizens were even on
the brink of starvation
there needed to be a revival of jobs for
the middle class
enter major ivanhurst of the british
army
he took control of the bombed vw factory
and restarted production
now finally the first beetles began to
roll off the production line
these first beetles were made for the
german postal service
interestingly around this same time the
ford company was given the opportunity
to have vw
free of charge but they declined because
they thought the company was worthless
by 1948 ferdinand was no longer directly
involved in the beetle but went on to
work on another project
the porsche 356 it was the car that
began
the porsche legacy
[Music]
in 1950 ferdinand took one last tour of
the factory and was happy to finally see
his vision being realized
he would die one year later at the age
of 75.
the early success of the beetle was
limited only to europe
in america the car was a hard sell large
powerful cars were the state of what
1950s america stood for
the bigness of our fast-moving
modern america come on kids let's load
up
just fold down the seat and presto
plenty of room for everything and
everybody
inside you'll find this lady's beauty
vanity this luxury is standard equipment
on all the larks
how would you convince the americans to
buy such a small underpowered trundle
mobile
clever honest advertising would prove to
be a charm
but the initial gateway was made through
a deal where u.s car retailers had to
buy
three beetles for every jaguar a car
which was very much in demand at the
time
as it turns out after the americans got
a taste for the beetle they actually
ended up loving it and the jaguar became
a sideshow
as the river of production increased the
beetle began gaining worldwide
recognition for its reliability due to a
high standard of engineering and quality
control
what is it it's a 200 year old
volkswagen
they really built these things didn't
they by 1955
volkswagen had produced 1 million
beetles
the late 1950s and early 60s saw the
peak of the beatles popularity with some
customers having to wait 12 to 18 months
to receive their order
it was even becoming an icon of the
counter-cultural revolution happening in
1960s america
the success of the beetle allowed vw to
acquire audi
in 1965 always looking bright for
volkswagen at this time
but the beetle fever wouldn't last
forever and sales began to decline in
1973.
as a reaction to this vw came out with
an old new generation of cars
out of this decision came the passat
golf
and polo in the 1980s they would acquire
a 75
stake in the spanish car manufacturer
seat
in 1998 vw would add bentley
lamborghini and bugatti to its portfolio
two years later they would also take
skoda on board
2010 saw vw acquired the italian
automotive design house italdesign
kugario this was a pretty big deal as a
tail design is credited with the
aesthetic creations of a wide variety of
cars
for various companies including alfa
romeo aston martin
bmw chevrolet fiat ford
ferrari hyundai lexus lotus
mitsubishi and several others their
designs always stood out as classically
futuristic
the most famous of them is the delorean
dmc-12
in 1981 it was of course the car used in
the back to the future series
in 2012 vw subsidiary audi would
purchase italian motorbike maker
ducati further increasing vw stature in
the automotive industry
today vw has turned into one of the
largest and most valuable companies
it is ranked seventh in the 2016 fortune
global 500 list
it has a market cap of 63.8 billion
dollars as of november 2016
and has maintained the largest market
share in europe's automotive market for
the last two years
vw is responsible for producing 13
of all passenger cars globally in 2015
it produced
9.93 million motor vehicles this
translates roughly to 19
cars every minute this is the second
largest number of any manufacturer on
the planet behind toyota
in addition to the other car brands
mentioned earlier vw also owns
man trucks and porsche in total they
have approximately 340 subsidiaries
the company has over 610 000 employees
for perspective ford and general motors
have a combined workforce of 448
000 and vw's biggest competitor toyota
has about 346 000 nearly half the amount
that volkswagen has
volkswagen's employee force is a figure
larger than the armed forces of
australia
italy croatia and norway combined
the company has 121 production
facilities in 20 european countries and
a further 11 in the americas asia and
africa
vw operates in a total of 150 countries
they do more than just manufacture cars
though volkswagen financial services
operates in 51 countries and specialize
in loans
investment insurance for both private
and business enterprises
okay so we're nearing the end of the
video but first let's take a look at a
few fun facts about volkswagen
number six the classic vwb tool was
built from 1938-2003
during this period 21 million 529
464 beetles were built it is the longest
running production model of any car and
vw claims that it is the best selling
car in history
since it did not change substantially
during its production run
toyota has sold over 40 million corollas
since 1966
but the corolla nameplate was applied to
11 generations so it cannot be counted
as the same model
number five on the 18th of september
vw was caught cheating on a mission test
via a software code that detected when
emission tests were being conducted and
altered emission controls for better
results
affected cars emissions were 35 to 40
times for legal levels
this incident known as dieselgate led to
a drop in the market value of volkswagen
by
30 billion dollars it was a shameful
period for the vw
group but the fallout from this incident
has mostly passed
number four volkswagen names some of its
cars after wind currents across the
world
for example the polo is named after the
northern polar wind
the passat is named after a german trade
wind the jetta is named after the jet
stream in subtropic to middle latitudes
number three three volkswagen cars were
named in the list of the top 10 best
selling cars ever
the volkswagen passat golf and beetle
number two an entire town was built to
accommodate for the workers of the first
vw cars
it would become wolfsburg the fifth
largest city in the german state of
lower saxony
the local football team is owned by vw
and is ranked
30th just behind liverpool in the uefa
league standings
the wolfsburg vw plant is still the
largest car factory under a single roof
in the world number one
in 1932 stalin invited ferdinand porsche
to the soviet union
stalin wanted to advance industrial
development in the soviet union with the
help of experts from capitalist
countries
he offered ferdinand the position of
general director of development for the
soviet auto industry
according to porsche's son after much
consideration porsche refused
the reason not the fact that it was the
soviet union but more so
the language barrier how could he manage
such a colossal engineering task
if he couldn't even communicate in the
native tongue so in a quirk of history
if porsche accepted the beetle could
have been a symbol of the soviet union
so with that that brings us to the end
of this video but there's one
question remaining so without a doubt
porsche was a genius engineer and
designer
the one in a lifetime kind but the
shadow of the nazi legacy
still hangs over his work so the
question is and historians still debate
was pushed purely into the technical
details of building a car for the masses
and like many people of the day didn't
comprehend the political climate
or was he actually fond of hitler some
even say that he had no choice in the
matter
and would have been put to death by
hitler if he had refused his offer
regardless everybody can currently
appreciate the engineering prowess
vw group has under its belt today
okay so that's enough for me i hope you
enjoyed this video about the history
size and some fun facts about the vw
group
if you want to see more videos like this
or other cool stuff feel free to
subscribe to this channel
if you know someone that might be
interested in this topic or maybe even
drives a vw
show them this video this has been
degogo you've been watching cold fusion
thanks for watching and i'll see you
again for the next video cheers
have a good one cold fusion
it's me thinking
[Music]
you